Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
De marineros que se transforman en cerdos,
ninfas que brotan de los árboles,
y una mirada que convierte
al espectador en piedra,
la mitología griega
rebosa de formas cambiantes.
Los dioses poderosos por lo general
cambiaban sus propias formas a voluntad,
pero para los mortales,
las mutaciones a menudo eran indeseadas.
A la tejedora Aracne le sucedió una de
esas transformaciones desconcertantes.
Aracne era la hija de un comerciante
que pasaba sus días tiñendo en tela
los tonos más profundos de púrpura.
Tenía un don para hilar
las mejores hebras
tejiéndolas en la tela que fluía,
y creando magníficos tapices.
La gente acudía en masa para ver
sus manos volar sobre su telar,
como si el hilo surgiera directamente
de las yemas de sus dedos.
Pero conforme los elogios por su trabajo
crecían, también lo hacía su orgullo.
A Aracne a menudo se la podía escuchar
alardeando de sus habilidades,
declarando que su talento superaba al de
cualquier otra persona: mortal o divina.
Se negó a ver el tejido
como un regalo de los dioses.
Por el contrario, hizo alarde
de él como su genio personal.
Desafortunadamente, la diosa de la
sabiduría y la artesanía, Atenea,
escuchó a Aracne
hacer estas afirmaciones.
Planeando dar una lección
a la ingrata chica,
Atenea se disfrazó como una anciana
y caminó sigilosa entre los mortales.
Reprendió a Aracne en público:
¿cómo se atrevía la tejedora a afirmar
ser más grande que los dioses?
Pero Aracne solo se rió,
apenas levantando la vista de su telar.
Provocada, la anciana se quitó la capa
para revelar su verdadera forma.
Si Aracne insistía
en difamar a los dioses,
Atenea la desafiaría
a un concurso directamente.
Enmascarando su sorpresa ante
la aparición de la diosa de ojos grises,
Aracne aceptó el desafío.
Atenea sacó su propio telar reluciente
mientras una multitud se reunía para ver.
Las tejedoras comenzaron, con los ojos
fijos y las lanzaderas desdibujándose.
Atenea conjuró
volutas de nubes desde lo alto
y esbeltos hilos de hierba desde abajo
en un espectáculo de destreza.
Tejió tremendas escenas que mostraban
el poder de los dioses:
Poseidón montando las olas,
Zeus disparando rayos,
y Apolo volando por el cielo.
En el magnífico tapiz de Atenea, la gloria
de los dioses empequeñecía la vida mortal.
Pero Aracne no tenía interés
en estimular egos divinos.
Su tapiz mostraba a los dioses
abusando de su poder:
peleándose entre ellos,
bebiendo y presumiendo,
y entrometiéndose
en la vida de los mortales.
Representó a Zeus como un mujeriego,
transfigurándose a sí mismo
para atrapar a las mujeres:
un cisne para Leda,
un toro para Europa,
una lluvia de oro para Danae.
Aracne luego recurrió
a los delitos de otros dioses,
del secuestro de Perséfone por Plutón
a la búsqueda salvaje
de Baco de Erígone.
A pesar de que presentó a los dioses
con la luz más desfavorable,
el trabajo de Aracne brilló
con su deslumbrante habilidad.
Su tapiz estaba casi vivo,
lleno de movimiento y colores brillantes
que titilaba triunfante.
Cuando Atenea vio el trabajo
indudablemente mejor
y flagrantemente subversivo de Aracne,
se enfureció y deslumbró
a la tejedora humana.
El júbilo de Aracne se atenuó cuando
sintió su cuerpo encogerse y retorcerse.
Sus dedos se agitaron violentamente cuando
sus brazos se pegaron a sus costados,
y el pelo negro brotó por todo su cuerpo.
La diosa dejó a Aracne con solo un carrete
de hilo desplegándose de su vientre,
un delgado recordatorio
de su talento humano.
Por desafiar la suposición
de que los dioses eran intocables,
Atenea había reducido a su adversaria
a la primera araña.
Hasta el día de hoy, Aracne
y sus hijos prolongan su penitencia
--¿o es una persistencia impávida?--
en las sombras de los gigantes.